in molte famiglie vengono fatti che
cambieranno le relazioni interne ad esse
io oggi vorrei parlarvi di uno di questi
molti anni fa mio fratello di cinque
anni più grande di me fu travolto da
un'onda che lo portò lontano
i suoi pensieri alla sua personalità non
furono più gli stessi di prima e fu
molto difficile comunicare con lui
da allora la mia famiglia è un trauma e
lui un dolore profondo
molti anni dopo perciò ho deciso di
capirci di più capire di più dei
problemi della mente capire di più di
queste malattie
e allora mi sono unità un gruppo di
persone interessate e abbiamo formato un
associazione l'associazione progetto
itaca
l'associazione progetto itaca ha come
obiettivi il supporto e l'attivazione di
progetti
che
prevengano che informino e che aiutino
le persone con le malattie mentali e
anche aiutino le loro famiglie
allora ci siamo detti cerchiamo di
capirne di più cerchiamo di capire cosa
vuol dire la salute mentale che entità
che tipo di problemi sono e ci siamo
imbattute in dati estremamente rilevanti
vi farò vedere solamente uno di questi
dati
spero di non terrori terrorizzati
quando poi parliamo di disturbi mentali
vedo delle mani alzate
quando parliamo di disturbi mentali poi
parliamo di disturbi più lievi
ansia quella che ho io adesso
attacchi di panico fino a malattie
conclamate più invalidanti e allora ci
siamo dette ma come mai se questi
problemi sono così enormi se i numeri
sono così significativi non se ne parla
di più non se ne sa di più di questi
problemi
e abbiamo capito che attorno alla
malattia mentale c'è un tappo che si
chiama silenzio stigma perché perché
queste malattie non si vedono non si
vedono come un osso rotto
dove si fa una radiografia e
immediatamente si vede dove la frattura
e si può ingessare sono malattie
nascoste sono malattie che
fanno paura fanno vergogna perché stiamo
parlando di persone diverse di persone
non allineate sappiamo che le persone
diverse fanno paura
però ci siamo anche detti cerchiamo di
capirci ancora di più perché perché
queste sono malattie come tutte le
malattie vanno affrontate
diagnosticate e curate
per cui abbiamo cercato non solo in
italia ma nel mondo di capire quali sono
i progetti che più sono efficaci per
questo tipo questi tipi di malattie che
sappiamo che sono appunto
una gamma molto ampia e ci siamo
imbattuti in un progetto bellissimo che
si chiama found the sounds è un progetto
che è nato a new york molti anni fa e il
suo primo diciamo fondatore ha spiegato
così il concetto alla base di questo di
questa istituzione
anche la persona che ha
un solo mignolo che ancora funziona cioè
la persona che è schiacciata totalmente
dalla malattia ha la possibilità di
lavorare su questo mignolo noi
lavoreremo su quello noi lavoreremo
sulla parte sana della persona
mentre la parte malata viene tenuta
fuori dalle lavori in parallelo
ovviamente alla nostra club house così
si chiamano queste istituzioni con i
medici professionisti di psichiatri
all'interno non c'è giudizio per la
persona che sta male ma viene
accompagnata in un percorso che è quello
di ritrovare pian piano attraverso delle
unità lavorative interne la sua capacità
di avere una vita sociale eventualmente
una ditta lavorativa
di queste club house cene
moltissime al mondo più di 300 qua
vedete una pianta dalla corea fino al
canada
dalla russia fino all'argentina e tutte
sono coordinate da clubhouse
international che l'agenzia che mantiene
uno standard molto alto mantiene la
formazione e controlla con un processo
peer to peer che queste funzioni non è
la stessa maniera con l'attenzione alla
persona
allora ci siamo detti ma forse
possiamo portarlo anche noi in italia
e così sono nati dei club itaca italiani
come vedete
delle foto di milano e di roma e nei
momenti sia di unità lavorative di
cucina e di giardinaggio e altri invece
momenti più sociali
allora abbiamo capito che per superare
il silenzio bisogna parlarne per cui ci
siamo informati e abbiamo cominciato
svariati altri progetti
progetti di formazione sia specifici che
generali
progetti di auto aiuto importantissimo
perché le persone che non stanno bene e
che hanno una difficoltà una paralisi
proprio anche nell'agire nel poter
parlare con gli altri possono parlare
con degli altri
abbiamo fatto un numero verde che
abbiamo fatto appunto queste clubhouse
io ne ho viste moltissime in giro per il
mondo
ho visto un ragazzo per esempio che
raccontava io ho cominciato a scivolare
piano piano verso l'isolamento
pensava che gli altri che i dottori che
gli amici che i parenti fossero i malati
invece il malato ero io e questo l'ho
capito solamente quando sono entrato
nella ed è ricominciato il mio percorso
di
attivare diciamo le mie capacità
un'altra un'altra ragazza invece giovane
una ragazza che voleva fare la ballerina
e lei diceva io vedo un dolore molto
profondo dentro di me
piangevo tutto il giorno mi chiudevo in
bagno per piangere
la decisione più importante della mia
vita è stata entrare in una club house
oggi ho un piccolo appartamento e un
piccolo lavoro e degli amici
questo vuol dire che è tornata ad una
vita di serenità di positività di
positività rispetto a quello che era
prima
tra gli altri progetti abbiamo come ho
detto prima la famiglia è un asse
centrale perché attorno alla famiglia il
primo anello attorno a cui
tutte le persone che stanno male si
appoggiano è quella che viene scardinata
diciamo da queste malattie abbiamo fatto
un bellissimo programma che si chiama
family and the family famiglia a
famiglia un programma che insegna ai
familiari cos'è la malattia sociale la
malattia mentale
il rispetto per la malattia il rispetto
per il malato capire se non vogliono
prendere le medicine quali possono
essere le strategie che aiutano affinché
il malato possa prendere in mano la sua
vita e
diciamo andare avanti nel processo di di
cura
poi ci siamo imbattuti in un altro
diciamo in un'altra realtà che ci ha
molto spaventato c'è un enorme gap c'è
un buco tra il momento in cui queste
malattie sorgono in maniera spesso molto
nascosta poco visibile al momento in cui
viene fatta la diagnosi e la cura come
vedete tra gli 8 ei 10 anni
8 10 anni sono un periodo infinito voi
provate a pensare ai tumori oggi
lasciare il tumore per 8 10 anni senza
curarlo è impensabile
però alcuni anni fa 10 15 anni fa non di
più non si parlava neppure del cancro
del tumore era si diceva il brutto male
che cosa una malattia che non si può
neanche nominare ecco noi vorremmo
arrivare a che le nostre malattie siano
affrontate si possa sciogliere questa
paura si possa sciogliere questo
silenzio che possano venire affrontate
come come oggi è stato il cancro
naturalmente sono processi di guarigione
dal cancro si guarisce si previene dalla
diabete si guarisce si previene si
convive molto bene molta gente convive
con queste malattie lo può dire anzi c'è
molta empatia verso queste malattie
verso le nostre assolutamente no
poche settimane fa siamo stati a un
congresso a bolzano dove è stato molto
interessante vedere una diapositiva di
un grande ricercatore forse il primo
padre della riabilitazione
ecco qua parlando dei forse della
malattia più più grave più invasiva
della schizofrenia
lui dice che il numero di pazienti che
riprendono la loro vita che migliorano
sostanzialmente la qualità di vita e lui
lo fa con dei dati scientifici
molto forti sono tra il 40 e il 70 per
cento dei casi noi stessi della nostra
associazione siamo rimasti stupiti di
questo numero perché è un numero molto
alto per cui parlarne è importante e
bisogna andare avanti in questi in
questa linea diciamo un progetto itaca
ha fatto il suo slogan
parlare è il primo passo per uscirne
magari qualcuno di voi l'ha visto la
alla televisione e poi abbiamo fatto uno
spot abbastanza provocatorio
che si chiama un minuto di rumore minuto
di rumore con un'agenzia che ci ha
aiutato a metterli insieme è stato
una giornata dal 10 di ottobre che è la
giornata della salute mentale in tutto
il mondo
siamo andati in giro per milano facendo
rumore con campanelline con
palloncini e
devo dire che è stato molto bello perché
tutto il web sia ritornato dai video che
poi sono stati montati anzi abbiamo già
vinto un premio con questo video di
ragazzi che scendevano le scale
battendo su delle bottiglie d'acqua che
si rompevano di altri che in ufficio
battevano quello con la calcolatrice di
tutto è tornato e hanno montato un
bellissimo video che però è troppo lungo
qua oggi che farvelo vedere per cui vi
farò invece vedere un attimo quello che
è successo per strada a milano ed è
invece un video molto
amatoriale nostro
mare un palloncino e dire che siano
bisogna fare un minuto di ritorno
la giornata fondamentale assolutamente
va bene vedere la maglietta
pietro
andiamoci palloncino sempre la testa
scoppia
o
no
c'era anche nella musica c'era anche
qualcosa di meno rumoroso però devo dire
che è stato un grande ritorno anche per
noi vi di accompagnamento mentre non di
paura una di accompagnamento
oggi il progetto itaca in cinque città
italiane abbiamo tantissime persone che
ci vogliono aiutare appunto non siamo
più da soli siamo riusciti un pochettino
a sciogliere questa paura
io vorrei che sono qua sul palco proprio
per chiedergli di
aiutarci a far sì che mai più nessuna
persona che ha una malattia mentale o un
suo familiare debbano vergognarsi
di soffrire di queste malattie e li
voglio invitare a raggiungere il nostro
grande e piccolo esercito rumoroso di
taka con il cuore per la mente grazie